[Laughter]
okay thank you I appreciate you setting
the ambiance but that's a little too
much smoke machine okay there you go
okay sorry willing to cash I think it's
going hey how's shooting just to say hey
I got it the doors discuss their looks
oh well looks like we're all in this
bowl of fish together who's the traitor
I don't know I'm trying to figure out
how to let you guys out now that's
ridiculous
that stirred yes in here all day
that was like a traitor thing to say no
letting us go to Egypt
you guys are good you guys are good good
okay I drop look good I'm wasted I'm the
good guy
oh yes if there are times in the way I
was one of them I'd for the cars the
other what I press to get the base the
the shield doors open your purse if I
want to things oh oh thank you the star
gates open hey everything okay this
round I promise I won't kill anyone
until the spigen ready everyone
screw you all right I'm killing mark
first so he doesn't kill everyone so you
get the Stargate everyone oh okay the
stargates good oh it's just like in the
movie it's all blocked good yeah it's
all blocked off this is the only room
again he is oh oh no we're trapped in
here what is this do really sounded like
[Laughter]
the crates or they had all their ammo
and everything that's crazy
[Laughter]
everyone dies no matter
everyone's dying right now negative when
the round begins in the face it's
preparing you're not anything and making
magic in there they make you magic okay
we get to hear we got to secure the area
just so I can test my theory okay how do
you start the we have you started
are you I'm right I'm mother blast doors
on the computer press press all the
buttons and I'm sure so everybody
departments okay got it got it so you're
trading you'll give it a see through for
through yeah yeah yeah we're just that's
open the star game and they know it okay
okay okay okay
alright we do know me in the closet
I mean nothing now you can lose coming
out of the closet though Hey I see how
it is what they trying to snipe me
what's happening here possibly what shut
on me
okay returning my calls
yes no now extremely quickly
tactical on your end is gonna be quite
we can think of [ __ ] nine predictions
Bob
spine citation action did you just say a
shits name that's it sparkles oh wait
it's gone
take the sparkle dick sparkle sparkle
dicks confront me about something a meet
[Laughter]
you've been star gated uh yeah you
should respond actually hold on let me
let me unless it happened after the
timer went down well then go for Vasa
hair so if Mark is alike he's a traitor
and being sneaky yeah I'm going to to
Egypt and beyond are you oh hey there
hey go go hello
alright you can try your c4 tactic what
no I'm already through [ __ ] alright I
would like to buy a rifle please
menacing Russian but I can only pay by
credit account Oh sweetie oh you're not
getting my [ __ ] rifle I have one
anyway
oh that sounds like a trader thing to
say if you ask me if I was a trader I
won't be telling my back to you now
would I
[Laughter]
don't die don't die okay cool
I'm looking for mark apparently my card
is rude me out because I thought he was
dead eyes are open to seeing the clothes
that he's in the closet come on you
can't open the doors to kill you oh no
those wrong just for fun should Google
mark a mesh yeah is it really is it
really bad it's awful but some of them
take it a little to the next level okay
don't forget shipped with it there's a
little bit of like maybe sexual things
taking place yeah maybe just a little
bit yeah yeah felt things read adult
things basically I am truly sorry and I
am I'm suing them okay you heard it here
you're just sue Tobler for allowing us
post yes
try think you're good like popular ships
I'm seeing my lawyer tomorrow thank you
the worst thing is this Sherlock and
John Watson I don't I don't like that
one I play the killer Klowns games and
let's see what they mount each other in
one of the way it's Jesus
creating a crime scene and they
literally like like like what's a nice
town industry and homes like climbs on
his lap amazing it is brilliant
mark and I being very quiet it's
probably yeah yeah I'm looking at all of
you
he said he's in the room whatever thing
drop huh now hold it I've seen you guys
walked by me a million times do you ever
see any indiscriminately last time okay
why is that bodies was also a traitor
and she'd heard me he's just trying to
be like like dominant IVs buckle so they
like make a mark epochal school was
Markel Sparkle that was my nickname at
school I'm dead serious
no it was just us I had long hair
someone threw sparkles in my hair so I
was sparkly for like a week
markup are khals Margo sparkles this
I've never seen this room down here
before it's this Stargate parking over I
don't like it
captain smoking hi I'm ash are you
innocent so tell me now whatever I say
pretty please would anyone like I am
innocent I am innocent
you promise I promise look they're going
into the start okay let's go in this bag
- what is the Stargate
well decipher strips party everyone how
about I turned off did you turn off my I
just know it's it's just stuff down got
a power to make this thing work my star
[Music]
they said something weird happens I want
to know
right now yeah I'm innocent what are you
talking about you would like as you can
control the size
[Laughter]